let's talk about kashmir the
indie-administered part in particular
it's been under a security and
communications lockdown
ever since india scrapped its autonomy
in 2019.
but what is going on on the ground and
why is india administered kashmir such a
hot spot
[Music]
let's start with the big picture kashmir
is a divided region controlled by three
nuclear powers
china india and pakistan but on this
episode we're going to focus on the part
that india controls
the vast majority of the nearly 13
million residents here
are muslim though hindus buddhists and
sikhs live here too
it's also naturally stunning kashmir's
gorez valley and the green rolling hills
around it are rich in
agriculture the indus river an important
water system in south asia runs right
through it
and it's one of the most disputed
regions in the world
so why is that here's a very quick
version of a long and also
very debated story the british
government's final decision
as to how power was to be transferred
from british to indian hands
after the british left the indian
subcontinent in 1947 it was partitioned
to create two new nations
hindu majority india and muslim majority
pakistan
several princely states could choose
which country to join and kashmir was
one of them
and kashmir was a muslim state the ruler
was a hindu by the logic of partition it
should have gone to pakistan
but it didn't according to some
historical accounts the hindu ruler of
kashmir at the time a man named hari
singh
was actually considering independence
but ended up exceeding the muslim
majority region to india
in 1947 india and pakistan went to war
over kashmir
the united nations took up the issue and
classified jammu and kashmir as
indian administered so the terminology
of it administered really just means
that it's uh
temporal it was the u.n that then kind
of uh passed a resolution on kashmir
which was basically calling for
self-determination or plebiscite to
happen in kashmir
that vote on self-determination in
kashmir never happened
and india and pakistan ended up fighting
two more wars over india administered
kashmir
that conflict has been a major
international story for decades
[Music]
everyone tries to portray kashmir as if
it began in 1947
as a dispute between pakistan and india
which is very reductive way of looking
at kashmir you also have a people who
are
who are demanding an independent
sovereign state
now the people of kashmir did get some
autonomy in 1949
and that was because of article 370 in
the indian constitution
it gave the region of jammu and kashmir
a special status
meaning it could have its own prime
minister its own flag its own
constitution its own legislative
assembly
india would have control over kashmir's
foreign affairs defense and
communications but in the summer of 2019
that autonomy was revoked india's
lawmakers
suddenly scrapped article 370.
a sudden and momentous decision india's
government says
it's revoking special privileges granted
to indian administered kashmir
india shut down communication no
internet no phones and security measures
like curfews were imposed
and local activists say thousands of
people including activists and
even pro-india politicians were
reportedly rounded up
so why did the indian government revoke
article 370
a lot of welfare schemes could not be
implemented because of the
restrictions under article 370. so this
was
actually a provision which was harming
the development of kashmir
and that's why it has been scrapped in
fact prime minister narendra modi had
made a campaign promise to strip kashmir
of its special status
when he ran for re-election in early
2019.
he explained the move this way
so what's modi talking about there let's
start with separatism
remember we mentioned kashmiris have
long wanted their own state
well over time separatist groups entered
local and national politics in kashmir
to challenge
pro-india political parties and their
supporters then
in the 80s armed groups were formed some
say they're fighting for independence
others want kashmir to join pakistan
india describes these groups
as terrorists after many attacks on
indian forces
and civilians in 1989 hindu residents
known as kashmiri pandits were being
targeted
hundreds were killed and tens of
thousands left kashmir
today a separatist armed uprising still
exists in india administered kashmir
and india accuses pakistan of directly
supporting it
it's one reason why new delhi says its
military needs to be there
one of the first things you do notice in
india administered kashmir is
indian soldiers they're everywhere
around 250 000 of them were here in 2004
but today it's thought there are as many
as 700 000
that's nearly half of india's entire
active military
the presence is there for defending the
territorial integrity
of india because of hostile pakistan
it's a normal thing so when there is
tension with china there are security
forces which are deployed in northeast
so why is it only that it is
intimidating in kashmir
because there has been a systematic
extremism
which has been patient rise by a few
people even by the indian government's
own admissions
at any given point there's really only
two to three hundred
militants or people who have picked up
arms in kashmir
and thus it kind of really lends itself
to the idea that
the army is not there to fight the
militants the army is there to occupy
the people kashmiri activists say
india's use of force has been excessive
one example in a recent united nations
report
found that out of 160 civilians killed
in 2018
29 people died and shelling and firing
along the line of control
with pakistan 43 were killed by members
of armed groups
and 71 people were allegedly killed by
indian security forces so what you've
seen over the years in kashmir is this
cycle of violence
disputes and very often big protests
which sometimes
stretch on for months
the communal passions are burning hotter
here than they have in decades grief has
become a way of life
the worst unrest in the cashmere valley
for six years
daily life is very difficult people
don't go to school many weeks and months
of the year
businesses remain closed for a good part
of the year as well
because of curfews or strikes meanwhile
the whole of indian-administered kashmir
has formally been split
into two indian union territories one is
jammu and kashmir the other is ladakh
it means they're now directly governed
by new delhi
and any form of autonomy is officially
gone
although kashmiris say that's sort of
been the case for a while
in many ways over the past few decades
that autonomy has been completely eroded
but what remained was something else
called article 35a
which basically gave kashmiris their own
rights to their land
which meant that only state subjects of
jammu and kashmir could buy
and sell property in kashmir now india's
argument has been that actually
article 35a discriminated against indian
citizens living in the region
but many kashmiris feel that land was
all they really had
and fear that any aspirations of having
that delayed u.n vote or their own state
one day
are gone too kashmiris are facing a fear
of settler colonialism
they are facing a concerted fair that
they might be dispossessed
the people who had any hopes that
india would at some point respect
kashmiri aspirations even they've been
completely
exacerbated by this step but that
doesn't mean the dispute is over
and few kashmiris will tell you they
feel at peace
there is so much more to what's going on
in kashmir than what we were able to
squeeze into a few minutes
just like the region every detail of the
story is hugely disputed and we just
gave you some basics so dig around
read indian pakistani and kashmiri
sources to get the full picture